there's a lot more to movies audio than
lines of dialogue in a musical score
there's also the sound that everyday
objects make footsteps in the sand say
or a spoon clinking against a coffee mug
that's the province of fully artists who
create those sounds which are then added
to a film or TV shows audio track so we
are here at the archive foley stage at
Skywalker Sound it was built from the
ground up and it's only been on
operation for just about six months and
I'm here with Shelley Roden and John
rash two of the masterminds who run the
sound gig here and have worked on all
manner of movies and other things and
we're gonna have a little fun today yeah
you're actually going to get your Foley
training license today signed by both
Shelley and myself you're going to
become a female rabbit today I dream
finally realized let's get into it the
mission was to do Foley for a scene from
the Disney Animation movie Zootopia but
while that might sound simple
there was nothing simple about making
those sounds
my first mission on the road to being a
Foley master was making rabbit footsteps
using rubber coated gardening gloves
chalk it up to beginner's luck but the
first go wasn't as bad as I thought it
would be first of I believe what you're
doing that in other words I was watching
the screen like you were I was hearing
it and I believed what I was hearing and
that's really the key to Foley next up I
had to replicate the sound of an
animated suitcase fully may look weird
but it's all about giving a scene
satisfying sonic texture that's pretty
darn good oh just say yeah I like the
character of what you were doing yep
well I gave it some backstory this
picture's been through a lot and then
the grand finale the sound of an
animated bunny flopping onto an animated
bed I had to get suggestions from the
pros for this one cold isn't here oh my
god that the advanced techniques of all
in my mind all right
that was perfect okay so you've done it
so Scott could you play the scene back
please ladies and gentlemen Peter greasy
walls rickety bed crazy neighbors I love
it
I have to say with a star cameo turn by
you with that second picture frame that
was it was a thing of beauty
thank you so much you did great